economía en las 24 estoy para eso con mi
compañera daniela blandón nuestra
experta aquí en la redacción de france
24 que nos va a contar lo más importante
de la jornada daniela y al lado de los
incendios que se registran en varias
regiones del planeta y que afectan la
economía o la liana mide un informe
publicado por la analista independiente
the conversation recogió testimonios de
expertos que han estudiado por muchos
años los efectos del cambio climático
sobre la economía el 2021 será
probablemente uno de los años más
calurosos registrados en la historia eso
para nadie es un secreto desde grecia e
italia pasando por rusia turquía argelia
y hasta en américa en eeuu canadá perú y
bolivia el calor extremo está causando
estragos que dejan decenas de muertes en
términos económicos hay tres efectos
principales según este análisis por un
lado a más calor menos crecimiento
económico
por ejemplo los trabajadores de
industrias expuestas a la intemperie
trabajan menos horas
por otro lado cae el rendimiento de los
cultivos un ejemplo es el colapso de la
cosecha de trigo en rusia
el calor de 2010 que elevó los precios
de este cereal en todo el mundo y
finalmente se dispara el uso y el precio
de la energía y los apagones se vuelven
más recurrentes daniela y entró en
vigencia estatuto migratorio andino
cuéntanos más así es los 111 millones de
habitantes de bolivia colombia ecuador y
perú pueden desde este miércoles residir
trabajar y circular libremente entre
estos cuatro países que conforman la
comunidad andina de naciones los
turistas pueden entrar por 90 días y los
residentes temporales pueden permanecer
dos años ambos prorrogables por el mismo
período
boliviano en colombia que un colombiano
en perú que un peruano en ecuador que un
ecuatoriano en bolivia sienta que esa es
su casa que es su ciudadanía que es su
territorio y que en consecuencia tiene
esa gran capacidad de moverse libremente
de instalarse libremente bien sea por
asuntos turísticos o bien sea por una
residencia temporal o bien sea por una
residencia permanente o definitiva
fue daniela y eeuu le pide a lópez
aumentar la producción de petróleo bueno
y no vamos a tratar de explicarlo hace
un año los precios del petróleo w de
referencia para el golfo de méxico
estaban en alrededor de 40 dólares por
barril desde que inició la pandemia los
países productores agrupados en la opep
más sus aliados liderados por rusia
recortaron la producción para frenar la
caída de los precios la demanda ya está
mejor y los productores abrieron el
grifo por lo que el precio ya llega a
los 70 dólares pero eeuu dice que no es
suficiente y pidió a la opep liberar más
barriles porque el precio de la gasolina
ha subido 42 por ciento en el último año
y quieren que baje hoy los precios de la
gasolina son más bajos que a principios
de esta década pero aún son lo
suficientemente altos como para crear
una presión sobre las familias
trabajadoras recientemente hemos visto
que el precio que las compañías
petroleras pagan por un barril de
petróleo comenzó a caer pero el costo de
la gasolina en las estaciones no ha
bajado
manila y el banco central del líbano
suspendió los subsidios a la importación
de gasolina si esta es una medida que
probablemente lo que va a hacer es que
va a encarecer los precios en un país en
el que de por sí ya han subido en más de
220 por ciento en el último año
provocando pánico y un próspero mercado
ilegal el banco central argumentó que se
está quedando sin reservas y dijo que en
lugar de subsidiar va a otorgar
préstamos para importar combustibles
algo que no cayó muy bien en medio de
una crisis energética que ha asumido el
país en horas enteras de oscuridad y ha
provocado una oleada de violencia entre
los consumidores que buscan gasolina
desesperadamente la escasez se atribuye
al contrabando el acaparamiento y la
incapacidad del gobierno de entregar
combustible por falta de liquidez
las cifras vamos con los indicadores de
la jornada primera manera hubo recortes
renovados en wall street para los
índices dow jones y standard and poor's
tras conocerse de datos de inflación y
en américa latina la bolsa de buenos
aires subió por tercer día consecutivo y
la cifra el día horas y daniela 111 68
millones dólares que pagar a la
petrolera shell a una comunidad de
nigeria para resolver un caso sobre un
derrame de petróleo que tuvo lugar hace
más de 50 años el incidente ocurrió
durante la guerra de biafra que duró de
1967 a 1970 y la firma de anglo
neerlandesa siempre ha sostenido que el
derrame fue causado por terceros ya que
en el año este días contribuyen con más
severas 24 punto com